we'll see if bill cosby gets a new
sitcom on nbc you know he got yeah he
got
acquitted he's out what yeah no
overturned by the court i haven't read
any of the details
uh my brother sent me this morning goes
you believe this i go no
so here it is this first time read it so
i don't know what's going on
pennsylvania's high court overturned
bill cosby's sex assault conviction
wednesday after finding agreement with
the previous prosecutor prevented him
from being charged in the case
cosby has served more than two years
that's it of a three to ten year
sentence at a state prison near
philadelphia
he vowed to serve all 10 years rather
than acknowledge any remorse over the
2004
encounter with the accuser he was
charged in late 2015.
the court said that the district
attorney kevin steele who made the
decision to arrest cosby was obligated
to stand by his
promise not to charge cosby when he
later gave potentially incriminating
testimony
all right this was no there was no
evidence that promise was ever put in
writing
wow they said that overturning the
convention and barring any future
prosecution is the only remedy that can
pull it all right
i don't get it why so i does anybody
know why
yeah anyone got this it was based on the
trial judge had a particular
accuser though so all the rest had
expired hold on the trial judge had
allowed just one
other accuser to testify at cosby's
first trial when the jury deadlocked
then he allowed five other accusers to
testify at the retrial
um wow
let me go all the way down here yeah is
there is and is in like what's
what's online is online like is
everybody like yay or somebody like how
dare you this just came out i haven't
even
seen much about it i mean we need like
saw songs ago current event will get
into it yeah yeah
that's crazy crazy right yeah but i
don't think
that i don't think he'll be offered a
sitcom anytime soon no you don't think
abc is like hey come with us now
do a reboot of fat alveolar yeah we know
you got those crazy eyes
not when that many women you know the
same story come out
so wait so he was he was sent to prison
for something in
2014 or 2004 well something like that
because it was the
statute of limitations had not yet run
out keep scrolling down you know there
were those other ones
there were so many women with the same
story he was found guilty
my hope is that decision will dampen the
reporting of sexual assaults by victims
we still believe that no one is above
the law including those who are rich and
famous
um and that's the difference between a
society that's a rule of law versus rule
of man
you understand rule of man there's
always the same that if you're a certain
guy you're untouchable
like a king or whatever this society was
based on the idea that everybody
no one is above the law law ladies and
gentlemen
our first lesson of today teacher
brian's in the house
i still don't understand anymore enough
here's what i worry about
they said split and then also like uh
what do you say they couldn't reach
i scrolled through it uh early this
morning i think they said something
about
uh because they used the testimony of
people who
accused him and the sexual limitation
had already reached its
limit so it influenced the jury because
like they couldn't do anything on them
so it influenced the jury
convicted are very specific like
i've been on a jury before i was on a
murder attempted murder trial
and uh there there was there were it
literally
all hinged the reason these guys went
away for like 15 years
was because they made a u-turn they made
the
they made a u-turn where they didn't
have to which proved that they came back
to try to shoot the guy okay and it was
that little detail the judge said i
don't care about that you're not allowed
to even deliberate or really talk about
the other things
this is resting on on did they make that
turn
what and somehow the turn was kind of
like it said you couldn't do a
u-turn and there was no reason for them
to do it
and but unless they were going back 15
years of their life hinged on
the jury saying and all of us were like
well leave that up first the only reason
it kind of says right there it says uh
he should never have faced charges after
striking a non-prosecution deal
with the previous district attorney more
than 15 years ago
so that probably came out the 2005
prosecution deal yeah that's
right because he there you go he worked
they they they worked out a deal with
him which is so weird
mm-hmm so he got off on techn some
technicalities yeah
yeah because they he did a deal because
they the the prosecutor the prosecutor
the d.a has to look and say what are the
chances of conviction
and and remember da's are political they
want
a so whenever they talk about like
kamala harris right they want
a 99 percent conviction rate it looks
good
it means you're tough on crime and
you're consistent so all those little
like things
so when you get caught on people away
yeah if you get caught on like you're
smoking weed
and they're not interested in really
putting you in jail they want you to
plea
out though because it's still a
conviction right it's still like you're
not you know what i'm saying you're
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no type in why did bill cosby get
off what did you say i'm sure there's a
layman's term there i mean obviously he
did a deal 15 years ago which it seems
like is why he got off
after conviction vacated bill cosby
officially
uh overturned the convention conviction
denied protection against
self-incrimination
orders released from prison after
finding that he was denied protection
against self
it's so complicated so he's done uh so
maybe he was forced to testify or maybe
maybe maybe they were using the
testimony that he when they deposed him
and they weren't supposed to because he
had made a deal 15 years ago
had given mr cosby his assurance they
would not be charged in the case
yeah so that came that news was
presented in court that he would never
be prosecuted and so then he spoke so
he'll so you can talk
and tell your story and you can't use
that story again against that same
person 15 years later that's probably
what it was
that's crazy though man that was
surprising when i saw my holy [ __ ]
no way damn hmm
he was still even when he was like going
through the court stuff he was still
doing stand up like selling out shows
and [ __ ]
well he dropped questions will he
continue to now i bet he does
yeah i think he his last special was in
like 2015
yeah or something like that how many
specials did he have we counted
21 20 21 something crazy like that yeah
damn yeah well if you watch what was it
on seinfeld and you watched seinfeld and
chris rock talking about
seeing him and they were like dude it
was as good as
anything i've ever seen he's a monster
yeah
so comedy monster not like yeah yeah you
know what i'm saying yeah you know
yeah there's uh i think yeah rogan asked
that question he was like man it must be
crazy
because you know he's really close with
uh harvey weinstein he's the one who
produced all his moves getting money for
the movie wow that was his partner he's
like he was like a father figure to me
he's like you know it was you know it's
sad what happened
to it it's sad that he did that and like
yeah
but he did say what was i thought was
interesting he said
anybody who was in his like realm like
in his
like circle knew what was going on like
for he's like any of those big stars you
saw him with
everyone was familiar with all the
stories we didn't know with cosby
with all those guys oh any of those guys
all those guys on
a rep yeah but with weinstein like
quentin tarantino was saying like
anybody who was in his atmosphere has
heard the stories like we all knew the
stories
nobody knew about rape but we knew like
quentin tarantino was like
he was like and by mistake like i
chalked up to like kim chasing the
secretary around the room like it was
just like
yeah we knew he was like you know all
about girls but nobody knew to what
extent
he's like if anybody tells you different
they all anybody in this circle knew
what was going on well i did because uh
my
my girlfriend of many years had that
experience
she was one of the first people to come
out against harvey weinstein she told us
that yeah
and she told me and then i then i found
out that a lot of
a lot of actresses had that story so
with i knew about that
15 years ago but you also knew he was a
he was
to do business with weinstein like i
remember two of my friends had a deal
with him they did the thing they were
like
i go how'd it go he goes it didn't go
through i go away well he just
lies and he's just unabashed he's just a
liar
like a straight up liar and it is what
it is it's who he is
yeah yeah let someone get in like that
though because he was
really good and he didn't get that
scripts were going to work he's good
super good he understood he's really not
what he does and story
that's the only reason anybody put up
with him yeah you don't look like that
and not be
you talk to him you hate me about that
the asians were like he was just no you
talked to anyone yet he's stupid
talented having an eye for it have an
eye for a movie and you look at his
resume like jesus christ yeah like
monster yeah yeah yeah but yeah quinn
tarantino on marin it's